we're joined now by the former
commercial secretary to the Treasury
under prime minister's David Cameron and
Theresa May Lord Jim O'Neill who was
also the chief Economist at Goldman
Sachs uh concept appeared now sits as a
cross Venture in the house of Lord thank
you very much for being with us our
program today
well it's the great Grudge Match isn't
it you know Boris Johnson versus Rishi
sunak but you know behind the soap opera
things are really really serious the new
prime minister will inherit an extremely
difficult economic situation and who
would you like to see become the next
prime minister
well and in your intro you describe me
as a cross-bencher so I think uh
consistent with me sitting on the
independent cross benches I I shouldn't
really have an opinion on such matters I
suppose but
um I I think if you look at what's uh
each has said about these issues in the
past uh Rishi obviously would be the
safer Pair of Hands uh and in many ways
what Jeremy hunts
uh has announced since he appeared on
the scene what is it only just over a
week ago it seems forever
um it's effectively what Rishi suggested
would have to be the case when he was
campaigning in the summer so I think
certainly fair enough to say that the
markets are conditioned
uh for for the kind of view that Rishi
would currently have whereas with Boris
As We Know
uh we don't quite know what you're going
to get let's say
yeah it's interesting isn't it uh you
know Chris Heaton Harris are saying that
he thinks that Bros will stick to the
Jeremy Hunt plan but we haven't really
as she said had a nailed down
explanation of what that economic Vision
could be do you think that might make
the markets a bit nervous
foreign
there are lots of other issues going on
on Friday I I read summaries about the
markets being uh worried again because
of the appearance of Boris in the in the
campaign but there's also a lot going on
in the US and in China and also uh
tricky issues looming in Japan with
financial markets so you have to be
careful some days big moves happen that
affect our markets that have nothing to
do with us but all of that said but the
markets because of the remarkable
self-inflicted damage of the past few
weeks are looking for fiscal credibility
in the UK
and they're sort of they were assuming
till Thursday we were going to get it
but uh it's very hard to see that if
Boris appears on the scene first of all
Jeremy Hunt would necessarily stay as
Chancellor uh and if Boris would want to
go back to everything he said
um as it's been a consistent theme of
many how how can he do all these things
about spending everywhere and keep taxes
low and they don't really go together
and at the end of the the day that the
big issue facing any leader in the
foreseeable future is we have a conflict
between
Promises of taxes to be as low as
possible a very strong public appetite
for spending and fiscal credibility and
and some things have to give obviously
and then on top of that and I really do
think it's very sad given the
self-inflicted mess there is an urgent
need to somehow get out of this product
so let's see uh trap that the country's
in and and somebody do something to take
because I asked a bit and I I did
personally Advocate to the treasury SEC
select committee earlier this year that
[Music]
[Music]
unfortunately it does look like that
link we're having a few problems with
the link to uh Jim O'Neill there
unfortunately we will let you know if
that is re-established okay well let's
try again cross our fingers
technical Gremlins all over the place
but we can see you so let's come back
excellent good stuff you were just
talking about the sort of economic
picture
um what how big is you know the black
hole in the public finances and how do
you think it should be dealt with
that's a short term because of what's
happened the country is going to have to
uh undertake fiscal consolidation and
fiscal credibility Above All Else
uh and so something along the lines of
what the obr was set out and what Jeremy
Hunter said he's going to do I don't
really see how we can Veer away from
that without uh an even worse reaction
from the financial markets unfortunately
um sadly it's only because of the the
nature and the style in which the
self-inflicted mess of the previous
leadership brought it around because we
do need to do something to to boost our
productivity rate and I think there is a
case for a different approach to fiscal
uh Behavior particularly a case of a
much bigger government spending and at
some point some government is going to
have to do that in this country but I
think that option is off the table for
whoever wins the leadership in the next
few days here
you know you've been you know a big
backer of the leveling up agenda you
know your Vice chair of the northern
Powerhouse are you worried what spending
cuts could mean to that agenda
well I'm worried uh specifically about
that of course and I'm also awarded more
broadly that it it sort of takes us back
to where we were in style uh to 2010 and
there are there are lots of major
economic challenges
um including obviously the the financing
of the Health and Social needs as well
as these Mammoth Geographic inequalities
in the country and we're only going to
be able to really solve them if if a
very patient source of investment
Capital appears and that very patient
source is the government but
uh I can't see given the damage the
government has created for itself and
for the country's reputation how they
can execute such a program in the very
short term without much bigger tax
increases but what what I think should
also therefore be happen happen as soon
as some kind of proper uh stability and
political stability and fiscal
credibility is established is this some
kind of request for a review of the
fiscal policy framework where you
actually as opposed to just announced
some random thing you ask all the expert
players like the obr maybe the bank of
England uh is there scope for having
let's call it a modern version of the
Gordon Brown uh Golden Rule where
government can invest more because
that's the only way we're going to get
out of this productivity trap in my
opinion but doesn't that mean more
borrowing which is what got us into this
mess in the first place well I I yeah of
course it does but I think there is a
very clear case
uh for more borrowing for investment
spending where
I would guess most economists you would
quiz would believe there are what
economists would describe our positive
multiplier effects which means the
future growth performance from that
investment spending will benefit quite
clearly uh and you'd have to do it in a
really sound transparent and approved
way by the likes of the obr otherwise it
would be problematical but uh I think
the case at some stage to go down that
path is very very strong but I don't
think it's an option that faces this
incoming leader because of the mass
his or her colleagues have created for
them
what do you think is likely to happen to
mortgages and also perhaps house Rises
house prices as well uh you know in the
in the short term
I think the the best that could be said
is if uh whoever wins follows through
with let's call it Jeremy Hunt style
promises mortgage rates will now not go
up as much as they almost definitely
would have done two weeks ago and if you
look carefully at what happened in the
markets over the course of the week uh
there's been a slight reduction in the
in the in the peak of interest rates in
the next 12 months that the markets have
had priced and if you look at what a
couple of Bank of England NPC members
said towards the end of the week they
they were implying I emphasized implying
that they might not tighten as much as
otherwise if we restore fiscal
credibility
okay and thank you very much indeed
really fascinating uh to talk and to get
your take uh on all of that thank you